chris is with us chris is in Pittsburgh
how are you Chris I'm good and how are
you better than I deserve what's up so I
recently came into a very difficult
financial decision I uh I own a Buick
Enclave I still owe about seventeen
thousand dollars on and now I moved to
South Carolina from Pennsylvania but a
lot more miles on it I thought and in
return obviously I was upside down on
the lurmen when I moved back to
Pennsylvania I got back up here and the
engine went in the car and there again
you giving me a quote about $8,000 for
place the engine who's giving you a
world of $8,000 for an engine yeah well
that's the engine that R is R it's a new
engine with 100,000 mile warranty for
the other options from Buick ah yes this
is the highest possible place on the
freakin planet to buy an engine no you
don't put that engine in that car not a
millionaire and I'm more than capable of
putting an engine in the car but it's
good you know from when I priced them
out they're still about five thousand
dollars to put it in no there's a Jasper
rebuilds not going to be that much for
that car not if you can turn a wrench
and drop that thing in there you're
going to be half that I maybe maybe not
have that but I mean this is just I mean
what do you make a year
I currently it just recently got another
job we moved back up to Pennsylvania I'm
making about a seventy thousand dollars
a year good how'd you blow the engine on
a car this new so apparently they have
timing chain issues the timing came
stretched it's about 20,000 miles oliver
extended warranty I bought a model lock
huh so it's a timing change all the
Sauter you blew it because the timing
chain was out yeah because of the timing
chain stretched or not and from the
timing chain stretching it went out of
timing and it's a type of engine that
when it goes out of timing it blows the
ends out right yeah they will if you run
it hard enough with that okay all right
okay so you're going to drop I rebuilt
something like a rebuilt Jasper I'm
giving Jasper a dadgum hat here but
there's people out there that do rebuild
or drop in a used engine out of a junk
yard exactly and you know the issue
without is it eventually it will most
likely have a mission I'm not saying
you're keeping the car but you can't
sell it the way it is you're you're
going to be so far upside down you will
be able to breathe so the things worth
sounded right making payments on the
product why I just recently got another
Rodgers recently got this other job and
I wasn't sure what I was going to do
with it so I mean I'm not only probably
two months behind that are now so you
think repo is a plan because you blew
your engine that's kind of what I was
going for
ah and how's that going to work out for
you well I would actually I'm just going
to make him a lump sum settlement
so ISO 17,000 on it I have about
thirteen thousand in cash that if I made
a lump sum settlement to get out from
underneath the car then you buy another
car but you seem to think or to think
Buick owes you something here well I'm
paying further for an engine to go a
little over one hundred thousand miles
they I mean I think that they should do
something but Buick isn't doing anything
but off I like financial may allied
financial didn't didn't put the engine
in the car I'll tell you what I lied
financials going to do they're going to
sue your but that's what they're going
to do they're going to laugh at you for
your little plan and they're going to
sue your but after they repo you so
you're going to lawsuit a repo destroyed
credit all because no dude this is
really a stupid but plan no absolutely
do not do this no but imagine if you put
an engine in it and sell the car and
write a check for the difference and
that way you don't destroy your credit
over this this is your responsibility
you're going to get eaten alive man the
legal system doesn't doesn't abide you
just feeling like you were
inconvenienced by Buick they don't go
along with that you signed a document
called a loan contract that you will get
sued on with allied and so no absolutely
no no no no no no no I'll put a used
engine in it sell the car write a check
for whatever you're in the hole after
the engine is repaired you can't sell it
the way it is because it's not worth
anything is worth Salvage like it since
with no engineering so put a used engine
in it
tell the buyer what they're getting and
make the loss on the car that way
write a check for the difference and get
out of Dodge in this case get out of
Buick this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]